die entscheidungen würden auch für die
grenzen offen oder rechts sein interesse
der bund an der stelle
ich kann nur eines sagen sollte am ende
möglicherweise innerhalb deutschlands
das reisen möglich sein kann ich jedem
sagen wir uns hüten da muss nicht nach
österreich sondern kann auch in bayern
dann macht das machen kann man wenn es
dann möglich jetzt wegen daran haben
oder man kann das wenn man nicht im
süden fährt und kann man da in bayern wo
denn nun hat auch super möglichkeiten
aber zu fangen
damit ist schon geklärt oder südwest ist
dann noch dabei die nächste frage frau
kunz von der rheinischen post apropos
west